buon pomeriggio a tutti grazie
garimberti ci sarà tutta una storia che
racconta mio percorso
in questo tema dei sogni sicuramente io
posso dire di avere realizzati missioni
credendo in me stesso nel mio lavoro è
così a dimostrazione di questo intanto
che ci saranno intrattenimento
sonoro audio e visivo chiamerei sul
palco vint cerf col quale interagirò
facendo un ritratto performance quindi
rieccolo di nuovo un altro grande
applauso
perché
è
un grandissimo onore per kevin se
sicuramente un grande mito giovare mito
iziplay si formi
non è il mito dell'alfa romeo e al mito
non è la macchina mito quello vero
quindi adesso ci organizziamo un secondo
siamo già pronti
giulia è già pronta quindi vita mia
ecco questa
questa macchina fotografica è
semplicemente una polaroid e non solo un
venditore ovviamente un rappresentante a
parlare di tante cose non li producono
più però diciamo che io dico credere ai
sogni perché quando così non riuscivo a
capire se andare avanti con la polaroid
o che cosa ebbe la fortuna di incontrare
un altro grandissimo autore fotografo
col quale diventa veramente amico che si
chiamava mario giacomelli mario
giacomelli aveva una macchina
fotografica tenuta assieme con dello
scotch e quindi ho detto se giacomelli
può tenere insieme la ma può fare quelle
foto che fa con una macchina col nastro
adesivo
io posso utilizzare la pole a rho e
quindi da lì
così ho realizzato questa scatola con un
ingegnere della polaroid di boston e da
lì è nato tutta la mia storia
quindi oggi siamo qua convinto allora io
direi di
in un attimo allora in
perfetto tanto me quanto me ok
perfetto domus chia camera
se anche molto non fatelo in serio
riguardo intero vogliamo parlare
soprattutto di me a meno che non si
tratti della fotografia una passione che
è cresciuta e maturata con me e che
quindi parla di me anzi parla per me ho
iniziato a scattare a 16 anni perché mi
affascinava guardare il mondo dietro un
obiettivo
quando andavo nei cantieri con mio padre
che aveva un impresa edile e sognava di
farmi diventare architetto mi piaceva
utilizzare uno strumento il livello che
misura i piani una sorta di binocolo e
mi allenavo a sezionare calcolare i
tralicci che reggevano i ponteggi
utilizzati per le ristrutturazioni edili
scomporre era diventato per me un
procedimento meccanico della mia mente
il senso dello spazio
l'ho appreso in questa maniera anche se
oggi c'è naturalmente molto più rigore
più matematica più geometria
mi interessava il procedimento tecnico
ma aveva un rapporto conflittuale con la
camera oscura non mi piaceva passare del
tempo in quel luogo
buio e
dover attendere per vedere i risultati
dei miei scatti mi rendevo conto che può
essere un limite per la mia professione
di fotografo che sognavo di
intraprendere
poi a 27 anni
ecco la polaroid iniziai a scattare con
le prime macchine e capi la potenzialità
di questo mezzo la polaroid
rappresenta una temporalità vorace tutto
e subito sono cosciente di essere un
mangiatore di immagini mi piace
rappresentare una realtà positiva e
nelle storie che racconto catturando ciò
che mi emoziona distinto in un istante
per me tratto il racconto visuale che
cerca di descrivere la personalità del
soggetto e mai e poi mai si sofferma su
una condizione momentanee d'arte fatta
per fare questo il mosaico costruito
attraverso l'utilizzo della polaroid è
un procedimento tecnico ed estetico che
risente molto di contaminazione
artistiche derivanti dalla scomposizione
delle forme cubiste dall'idea futurista
di movimento e velocità di boccioni
influenzato dal surrealismo di murray e
dal noto che scende le scale di masse
allo shampoo e dai readymade di murray
non mi limito a sezionare i volti quello
lo fa david hockney io cerco di
scomporre e decostruire le immagini line
ghiotto la elaboro cerco di manipolare
la realtà per restituirla completamente
ridisegnata anche attraverso i segni
pratici sulle polaroid il movimento
meccanico infatti da solo non riesce a
dare tridimensionalità
ritratto per fare ciò bisogna accogliere
le persone nella loro relazione con se
stessi cioè nel loro silenzio interiore
quando ritraggo non amo parlare il ritmo
silenzioso dei miei gesti a volte
spiazza i miei soggetti che spesso non
sanno dove guardare né come muoversi
rimangono fermi immobili in questa
mobilità
il ritratto è più interessante
dal fermo immagine scaturisce il loro
silenzio un silenzio che si moltiplica
fino a diventare una risonanza di echi
impercettibili e io cerco di tradurre
durante lo show questa sinfonia dei
pensieri emozioni riflessioni in una
composizione mentale per me ossessiva mi
sento un musicista
circo insomma di creare un dialogo
interiore una poeticità un lirismo che
lascia spazio a una sensazione di
indefinito di sospensione di assenza di
vuoto
stato la risposta al silenzio
all'immobilismo allo spiazzare il
soggetto che miei ritratti producono in
una frase della presentazione di jack
luc nancy al libro di henri cartier
bresson nancy scrive il vero ritratto è
quello in cui il personaggio
rappresentato non è colto in nessun
azione ne adotta un'espressione che
sfida la persona stessa lo stesso a un
riccardi e bressan dice cerco
soprattutto un silenzio interiore
cerco di tradurre la personalità e non
un'espressione lavorando sempre in
silenzio per non perdere la capacità di
mettersi in ascolto e cogliere quella
sinfonia di caratteri pensieri emozioni
ossessioni e sofferenze che fanno la
differenza tra un istantanea è un'opera
d'arte
ora sono qui a roma a te dix sono molto
felici di realizzare questo ritratto in
diretta è la mia vita l'ho sognata e
l'ho realizzata
ho letto poi della mia fotografia sul
fantastico l'altro ritratto di
jacqueline bensì una gioia scritta che
vale una vita
grazie a tutti
per un problema tecnico rifatto la
seconda fila
questo sono pellicole che sono scaduti
dal 2008 quindi hanno dei problemi
tecnici
eccoci qua
ok allora io thank you so much and now
ai composti di piccioni the uk why yes
please prigione chi è allora fai così
hai la
forza la susseguenti
portano anche questo perché si
avvicinano fastidio allora giulio va di
là
la carichiamo
equilibrista questa la teniamo che si
serve quando la portiamo via è bello
della diretta no allora vince perché
rischio metodi
4 5
9 10 sono le dieci che abbiamo rifatto
allora eccolo qua
ecco
come dicevo durante lo speech audio il
mio diciamo uno che mi ha molto
affascinato
entusiasmato è stato sicuramente
sia boccioni prima era di oggetti linee
dinamiche dei ritmi e poi ovviamente il
master usciamo quando il quadro nel modo
che scende le scale quindi il soggetto è
fermo e attraverso una scansione riesci
a dare un movimento ecco qua
proprio per il bello della diretta ci
sono due scatti che sono neri ma chi se
ne frega
andiamo avanti
noi brianzoli siamo caparbi
quindi ecco qua
questo qui è quella che abbiamo rifatto
c'è questo l'abbiamo rifatta quindi noi
siamo anche fortunati
perché abbiamo due tessere che ci
vengono in soccorso
ecco qua
abbiamo chiesto
andiamo avanti
stati vacui di solito non tifo niente ma
appunto avendo avuto un problema ho
rifatto una fila
ecco come dicevo la cosa molto bella
quando alle cartier bresson
quando non si vede ritratti dei campi
persone dice silenzio il soggetto è
assolutamente in silenzio e viene fuori
l'emozione che la vita ti dà
l'interiorità della persona
io spero che visse quando veda questo
suo ritratto si emozionerà per come per
quello che è in questa fotografia
ecco qua
io non ho mai il ritratto mia madre
perché sarebbe un'emozione troppo forte
davvero vedere un parente in questa
immagine è qualcosa di incredibile
quindi
non riuscirei a fare la fotografia mia
madre avesse glielo fatte da dire che mi
piace molto
eccolo qui il
prossimo marzo
fantastico vuol dire
venuto
hi hi hi fi for this is the motion
thank you so much
allora adesso vi faccio vedere anche
come li tiro su perché poi qualcuno mi
dice poi come fa in montagna noi tiriamo
su io non ho mai giocato a poker però
dovuto un po imparare quindi l'hai fatto
vedere tutto a posto allora partiamo
così
come faceva pozzetto nel film il ragazzo
di campania tac
poi
e tac ed ecco il tavolo bianco e vis
equa e chiuso all
grazie grazie